it is not easy to pull off
a live action cg hybrid so were there
any films that did it really well before
that you used as
i guess a guiding light of sorts let's
be clear i had
the absolute privilege of working with
both disney
and npc who are a visual effects company
who together had worked on the jungle
book together had worked
on the lion king so
i was working with a team of people who
knew as much as anybody else let's put
it that way
the combination in our movie is
completely unique nobody's done it quite
like
us so you know there were amazing days
on set when i would turn around and i'd
be looking at my visual effects
supervisor and my animator
and they would be literally scratching
their head going okay
so how are we gonna do
this because however much prep we had
done
there's always moments that you cannot
quite anticipate
um so it was it yes and of course you
know i
often went back and watched moments in
in in both of those movies particularly
lion king i suppose
um which was such a pleasure to watch
um so it wasn't that we we could copy
them but there was always stuff to learn
from them and decisions that they'd made
were very very helpful for us for sure
how about when it came to directing
voice performances
for i believe the first time are there
any techniques you picked up that came
really handy in the booth
that you know you'll keep in your back
pocket if you do something like this
again
i didn't have any help with that other
than just threw myself in and did it
but in a way it's kind of like
working with actors doing improv okay so
they have the words they have the script
in front of them
when they're comfortable with each other
um so take danny and sam for example who
did
the majority of their work we did
together as a as a three
um they would
do the words on the page and then we
would do about
10 other versions in which they would
just riff off and come up with sometimes
wild things sometimes
absolutely gold uh a lot of the
the things that they just made up have
gone into the movie
um so in a way it's almost like
the most sort of purified way of
directing an actor because you don't
have to worry about costume you don't
have to worry about makeup you don't
have to worry about lighting you don't
have to worry about if the camera's in
the right place
you know you don't have to worry about
anything other than their performance
and in that sense
it was a complete joy working with all
of them and they were all so different
so brilliant brought completely
different things into the room um
so but it was great it was it was new
but a lot of fun
congratulations again and thank you so
much for your time today
thank you so much thank you